everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm and today we're gonna be
looking at johanna sucker tour it's a
mortal game his most famous game if
you're not familiar with him in the late
1800s he was the world number two player
behind Steinitz who won the world
championship for many years and his
opponent playing the black pieces is
joseph blackburn both of these players
we have many openings named after
Blackburn was one of the most dominant
British chess players also top of the
chess world in the late 1800s this
tournaments held in 1883 in the London
tournament and it has many of the world
champions or the people playing for the
world championship around that time
including Steinitz in this tournament so
very strong tournament this is not some
amateur game or you're gonna be seeing
some crazy moves against some weaker
opponents these are the top players in
the world at the time so circuits are
playing the white pieces and then
Blackburn defending with the black
pieces so Couture starts out with pawn
to c4 after pawn to e6 plays pawn III
had the option to go Queens gambit line
but instead decides to go do with your
traditional English opening not f6
Knight to f3 and then pawn to d6 now
different generations like different
openings at this time it was not very
common for both sides to be fitting
feeing canoing their bishop here to b7
and g7
kind of playing the hyper modern defense
not very common but that's exactly what
Blackburn's looking to do here Bishop to
e2 getting ready to castle on at the
King side Bishop db7 trying to control
these center light squares and the board
casts on the King side pawn to d5 pawn
up here to d4 really controlling these
dark squares right now Bishop to d6
opening up to castle on the King side of
the board Knight to c3
just simple development neither side
really looking to exchange right away
casts on the King side and then pawn to
b3 and this is opening up the door for
the bishop to come
to be - so not only is Blackburn opening
up the the repertoire here trying to try
something new because there's not as
much theory in opening games and this is
not very popular sucker toward decides
to go and do the same thing
pawn to b3 and preparing for his Bishop
to come here to be to Blackburn
continues his development getting his
knight involved into the game Bishop to
b2 as we talked about Queen to e7 and
development has been completed for
Blackburn the only thing and the
secretory has to do is get his queen
involved but the sides first to go ahead
and plate Knight up here to b5 attacking
the bishop we have a lot more theory
around the bishop pair and you can see
right away the Doctore realizes how
strong this is so decides to go ahead
and attack this Bishop right here and
there's no real great square for the
bishop to come to it is going to fall
wants to maintain control of this c7
square so he needs to come along and
this diagonal here if it comes down here
this is the only safe square then the
knight can just take up here in c7 so
recognizing that it is going to fall
decides to go and bring the knight down
here to e4 this is a great outpost for
the night also if he wants to come back
and take here on d6 he has that option
white decides to go ahead and take here
on a d6 and then recapture with the pawn
here on a d6 now sometimes you don't
want to have a double pawns but in the
center it's not necessarily a bad thing
especially if you have a partner over
here on the connecting a file you can
really control a lot of the start of the
board you can see that black controls
both the light squares and the pawn here
on a d6 really controls these dark
squares as well white can't come up here
to e5 things like that this does also
open up the door for a semi-open file so
if black wants to bring this rook over
here to c8 or a good swing over tower
over here from the F file as well he can
now control that get his rooks involved
into the game then I comes back here to
d2 recognizing that yeah it's not gonna
be doing much here coming to e5 so wants
to position a little bit
differently plays night here 2d to
Knight to f6 just defending the knight
here on e4 does not want to have the
knight come to e4 and then take with the
pond that's not the double pond he's
looking for on the e-file doesn't have
the protection that he would want from
the pawn back here on d6 so the pawn
comes to f3 forcing the knight to move
could say yeah let's go ahead and
exchange if you want to that's exactly
what Blackburn decides to do and then
the Queen takes here on D to completing
development for white as well now we
start to see some pawns come off the
board blackburn decides to go ahead and
take with this pawn here on at c4 this
does also get rid of the double pawns
here in the center of the board Bishop
takes just getting that strong light
square diagonal up here on a c4 this
does also allow for the bishop here on
b2 and the bishop here on c4 to really
control these long diagonals right away
we see Blackburn play pawn to d5 just
blocking the center of the board also
wants to make sure that this light
squared bishop doesn't do too much so it
comes back here to d3 rook over here to
c8 trying to control this now open file
completely and white has a couple
options could decide to go ahead and
counter-attack maybe rook to c1 and just
say I don't want you to control that
circuit or decides yeah I don't care
about that at all and plays rook over
here to e1 now this is his immortal game
and sign it so afterwards since he's at
this tournament and they're watching the
other players in the competition see how
they're doing they're reviewing the
games as well he said this one's the
grated one of the greatest chess games
of all time this is one of those moves
that is people are analyzing they look
at and recognize just how great this
move was and what it really led to later
on into the game but really Zuckert or
looked at this and said yeah I don't
care if you control this open file right
here
I want to dominate the center of the
board and really with both of my bishops
lining up on the Kings side the board I
feel like I have a strong attack coming
up so I'm gonna go ahead and put
everything I have
that basket so rook here to e1 rook to
c7 have to continue with the game plan
if you're gonna control this open file
you have to play rook to c7 you have to
swing your rook over here to c8 double
barrel here and try to attack on the
Queen side of the board white pretty
much has the game plan now I'm gonna
push forward try to open up this board
stay really attack my opponents that's
what he does place pawn to e4 rook to c8
and then
pawn to e5 trying to blow up the board
as much as possible the knight forced to
move so Knight up here to be 8 and then
pawn to f4 so it is it is all in now
there's there's no way to come back from
this decides to push all of his pawns
now forward as much as possible and then
pawn to g6 realizing that stuff's going
down so wants to stop it as much as
possible
rook to e3 so now decides I'm gonna get
my rook involved I can swing it over
here to the King side start to attack my
opponent and then pawn down here to f5
says one right away I'm gonna blow up
your pawn structure a little bit you
have one chance and one chance only four
on passant you can actually take right
here which is what happens in the game
and if not this starts to clog up this
side of the board which is what
Blackburn is probably thinking about
yeah I want to clog this up a little bit
and if you take hey that's fine I have
my night here on eh you don't want your
knight on the eighth rank so he's
looking at says yeah I'm okay with my
Knight recapturing here on f6 this is
exactly what happens in at the game
white looks at this and feels pretty
good about it plays pawn to f5 continue
as much as possible to try to break up
this board state on the Kings side the
board knowing that he has two bishops
eyeing down on the King side he has both
of his rooks and a king in a queen
excuse me so he just knows if he can
start to remove some of this material
he's gonna have a strong attack
somewhere now we see Knight down to e4
just as great little outpost blocking
some of the material here probably
better bringing the knight here then
pawn to f5 because then we have a
great little deflection here with the
bishop taking the pawn can't take here
you can see the queen is going to fall
maybe the rook comes over here to e8
trying to block something but then you
could just see ruck takes on e6
attacking the Queen maybe the Queen
takes Bishop takes rook to e6 there's
lots of different options here clean up
to f4 attacking the rook here on c7 you
could have the Queen come down here to
g3 check could eventually after check
take the pawn here on a7 so lots of
variation that these players are looking
at but in the game decides to go ahead
and play Knight down here to e4 Bishop
takes after the pond takes then the pawn
takes here on g6 so this is starting to
open things up another thing this does
does do is it opens up the door for a
discovered attack with pawn to d5 and
this is going to be very crucial later
on in the game so he's blowing up the
king side the board and also opening up
for a very deadly move of pawn to d5 at
some point knowing that his opponents
could eventually get his King on one of
these dark squares so after the pawn to
g6 then we see rook down here to c2 and
H takes on g6 it's just not really that
good of a move after rook to g3 really
hard for black to do anything productive
in this spot so we do see correctly that
Blackburn defends he plays the rook down
here to c2 now white continues with the
same thing as before and we see pawn
takes here on h7 and then the King comes
over here to HH recognising that as soon
as he takes this then the Queen and the
rook can start to come over here to the
King side aboard an attack
he's almost using this pawn as a defense
for himself now what we looked about
before is there still that discovered
attack with pawn to d5 and that's
exactly what we see here with check so
saying yeah you can go ahead and take my
bishop if you want to I'm just gonna go
ahead and take your rook right
here but does have to figure out how
he's going to defend this decides to go
ahead and play pawn to e5 it would have
been tough if he takes with his rook
here on b2 the Queen's gonna take here
this is going to be checked maybe pawn
to e5 at this point it's gonna take
material here on e4 then Queen down here
to c5 check King over here to h1 this is
a very good square but you could see
that white has a dominant position is up
multiple ponds does have two rooks and
the Queen here the rook can take up on
e5 this should be a pretty easy game for
for white to do and you can see even if
the Queen comes down here to d2 Queen is
being able to protect this so if the
bishop takes this is going to be a
pretty easy in game for white so as we
come here after pawn to a d5 we see
instead the pawn to e5 so it really
comes down to can white remove this pawn
here on e5 because there is a deadly
attack with both of these rooks and at
the bishop here on e5 to attack that
King so really that the move of the game
comes in this next move it's extremely
difficult to find that the fact that
secretory was able to find it one of the
reasons that this was his immortal game
but he founded the great move Queen to
b4 and says yeah go ahead and take my
queen I'm okay with that because all he
cares about is the Queen here on e7
cannot defend the square here on e5 so
if the Queen were to take which he
didn't then the bishop to come up here
to e5 and then there would be a mate it
would be quite a few moves but knowing
that he played the move Queen to b4
you're led to believe that he knew what
the the mate would be because he has all
his active pieces and those Queens
completely shut out is over on the Queen
side can't really do too much they could
just continue to check his opponent and
eventually he would have a checkmate on
the board so after Queen to b4 says yeah
go ahead and take my queen
burne says yeah I'm not gonna do that
plays rook down here to c5 then we have
rook up to f8 Scheck says please go
ahead and take my rook now I tried to
have you take my queen you didn't I want
you to go ahead and take my rook now he
does not decide to go ahead and take the
pawn right here if he takes with this
Queen it's not gonna be good
same thing as we saw before Bishop takes
on e5 check the queen is no longer
defending it now you almost are forced
to take with your your king here but
then Queen over to e4 check and then
over time this is going to be a
checkmate there's no way for black to
stop this so in the game does not take
of the rook right away decides to go
ahead and take with this King here on h7
Queen to e4 then we have King to a g7
Bishop to e5 and just really telling
them hey I'm gonna force you to take my
material here so the King takes on f8
and then we have yet another brilliant
moves it seems like every single move
the secretory does is phenomenal but he
finds great move with a deflection and
that is Bishop to g7 and there are so
many reasons that this is good one it's
check so black has to worry about that
right away if he takes with this King we
can see right away that the queen is
gonna take here on e7 check the bishop
could fall there's just nothing good
that's gonna happen for black here he's
going to lose that but if he takes with
his bishop or excuse me with his queen
okay
still it's going to be checkmate right
away clean up here to EA - this is
checkmate so there's just no good way
for black to deal with this he decides
to play King to g8 trying to do
something in the game but then Queen to
e7 and at this point there's really no
way to stop this you can delay the moves
by coming down here checking your
opponent but there's no way to
eventually checkmate the opponent so at
the end of the day we have Blackburn
decided to forfeit the game and Decker
toward one this game ended up winning
the tournament had an amazing display if
you're playing this high level you
expect him even with the best players in
the world including Steinitz to go ahead
and win the tournament which he did so
phenomenal game especially towards the
end finding all these moves that are
extremely difficult to find and it all
started when he realized yes I'm gonna
attack the center of the board I'm gonna
let you do your thing over on the Queen
side and really dominating with his
Bishop pair well we talked so many times
about having that Bishop here and
putting it to use that's exactly what he
did and then knowing that he had that
that discovered attack here just moving
his pawn up to d5 and blowing up the
King's had the board and those pawns so
that he eventually could unleash that
strong attack on his opponent so this
was a phenomenal game to review always
love seeing that the games from hundreds
of years ago of these players who were
still playing at such a high level I
feel like some of these immortal games
we don't get to see of as much nowadays
but it is always good to look at some of
these older games if there are other
games you would like me to review feel
free to let me know you can email me at
any time at the chess website at
gmail.com but thank you guys so much for
watching Zack retort immortal one of the
best games of all time it's always good
to go back and look at these thanks for
watching I'll see you guys in the next
video